hello welcome back to big mood we have a
bonus episode for you today
you're welcome um we also have a special
guest so you're welcome for this too
you want to introduce yourself special
guest hello my name is steve green aka
iceman aka cryptoking what's up he comes
from the podcast that they don't tell
you so plug the plug
um also i'm nikki for those of you who
are listening on audio who else we got
i'm tiff and jess and we're gonna tell
you whether or not
you should break up with your partner
today because um
we got we got asked for a lot of uh
situations
on our instagram if you're not following
us on instagram you should at big mood
girls we
ask for things a lot and you can be
featured on the podcast um
and so a few of you sent in your
situation ships
and want to know we're going to judge
them yeah now
you wanted us to judge them so you came
to us yeah
yeah you are going to give you the
brutal honesty these people asked for it
you asked for it we would not give you
unsolicited advice but
this is heavily solicited and we can
keep them all anonymous too because um
you know sometimes it's a little
embarrassing unless they ask to be named
yeah okay so here's the first one i
would love if you could make up a cool
name for me and not use my real name
okay what's the cool name lisandra
lisandra
that's pretty cool she sounds old but
okay gina says to lula she's
lisandra sounds like the girl in game of
thrones with the red hair oh you're
that's true oh yeah not cool enough for
jess
if she's red-headed then she's young if
she's not reddit headed then she's old
yeah
i don't know why that works but it does
so she's red-headed okay
uh not an if we should break up but i
wanted to hear how to get over a
long-term relationship
so me and my boyfriend well now x have
broken up after six years
it just happened today when i'm writing
this wow we're sorry
alessandra he was my first serious
boyfriend and i thought i wanted to
marry this man
turns out we're both tired of pretending
like we can force this and i know it's
for the best but like it's still hard
and like i said it just happened and now
we're in the phase of me having to move
out and start my life over
i'm scared and excited to relearn about
myself and grow
into myself but the part of me that
still loves him can't imagine myself
with anyone else
nor do i want to jump into another
relationship i don't know if i'm
so calm because i felt this coming or
because i'm still here
maybe once i move out the grieving will
become worse there's so much going on in
my head and i would love to hear from
you guys
that to me sounds just like the most
natural
that's like literally what it is
you're in like you feel calm because it
was what was meant to happen
in choice you're just transitioning out
in a routine too you you
you're basically in a relationship
routine like you weren't happy inside of
it
you got out and now you're scared of the
uncertainty you're not
looking forward to going back into it
it's like you just graduated from high
school
it's like what are you doing the weights
kind of lifted
so what are you going to do after that
but you actually got out of the cycle
this time so yeah so stick to your guns
yeah because it's hard for people to
break up when they should especially six
years
yeah i mean that's what i it was really
hard for me to
leave my last relationship because i
mean i i spent a couple of years
probably almost two years
longer than i needed to in the
relationship because i was just like
well he's like one of my best friends
like he takes care of me like we all
have a group together like my whole life
is kind of centered around this
relationship
why would i leave it you know like maybe
i'm not in love he's not really in love
but like we're so intertwined and it's
kind of like
convenience but and the feeling is very
scary but then once you kind of get over
that hump it's not scary anymore and i
think it's actually coming back you can
see you're like holy [ __ ]
i was in a black hole yeah why was i
happy there or why was i content with
that i've done
like and it sounds to me like she's kind
of
she's okay with the decision she
probably in her gut she knows it's the
right decision so honestly i don't think
it's gonna be
bad for her like i think it's gonna be
good for her she's gonna get to grow and
experience new things and it's gonna be
good like it was good for me i've
i don't wanna say glowed up as if i'm
like better than my relationship but
like i've done
i feel better now i feel stronger i've
done work on myself
so it was it's been a positive
experience and it sounds like from how
calm she's saying she is um that it
probably was a situation where
for the for maybe the past couple years
they've been in it longer than it was
supposed to and so i didn't like it when
she was like we finally got to a place
where we know we can't stop
like we can't yeah it doesn't yeah cause
those are the easiest breakups when
they're kind of mutual
yeah like you got hit by a truck with
some
terrible cheating news or something you
know and the getting over it part is
more so getting over
the routine of it like how
interconnected it was into your life
but waking up and putting on this
costume and pretending like you're in
something that's cool
yeah this is the worst feeling ever
that's that was kind of slowly killing
my soul
and i think my ex-partner soul is like
it was not
it was kind of like i don't want to say
it was fake but after a while it wasn't
really real either you know so
it's definitely soul cream the romance
part was fake it's like you still liked
each other
but not like the part that makes it a
relationship and not just a friendship
was
but how easy would it have been to just
go back i mean the night that you guys
broke up
on our couch been so [ __ ] easy yeah
on your couch yeah yeah yeah we threw
that couch out
and you did a cleanse of the yeah i
staged it yeah but no but
the easiest thing in the world is just
to go back to your routine and then get
put on the costume again but
but getting out good job you got out
stick to your guns man you did this for
a reason
yeah when you first broke up uh did you
feel like how she feels now where it's
like i can't see myself
being with someone else for that
immediate because i know for you like a
little bit
it was already like distant right but
then i guess like the fear of like oh
[ __ ]
having to go back out there and i think
yeah there's there's definitely a part
where
and you're right to not want to jump
back into a relationship because that's
the right
response to have especially after that
long but there's a little bit of you
where is like
man i spent five six years like letting
this person know who i
am i spent so long like i've built there
is a trust there right yeah
even though there's been disappointments
for things over the years like they
know you like they know me i can trust
it like i know i can rely
like i know i can rely on this person
and now you have to go from that to like
completely
exposed out in the open in the world
where there's nothing but [ __ ]
predators right is what it feels like
so that part where i'm like oh i don't
know if i could trust another man like
yeah obviously that's not the truth but
that's that's just a natural reaction to
like oh
everything's so bad out here yeah but
you know that's just something that you
have to deal with over time i'm still
dealing with that personally myself it's
been a year and i'm still
not probably ready uh even though i feel
like i
i am because i've grown a lot but
there's still a lot of where i'm like
a lot of guys are just yeah you haven't
met the right person yet that you're
like i feel like i could trust you but
it's okay to not be in a relationship
for a while
like i don't know i recommend it for
sure i feel like the
i had a relationship similar to this we
were together for five years and
definitely stayed like a year and a half
longer than
i should have but um i just wanted to
make it work so bad because of that
because i
felt like he knew me and what if i never
find
find somebody that can know me like that
and can understand me even though i
don't feel romantic feelings towards him
anymore i don't
ever want to have sex with him and it's
not fair to him because he's like
hey how come we don't do this anymore
and i kept making excuses
and i just felt like maybe you'd
eventually come back and it never did
and then i was like well maybe that's
how all relationships are
am i wrong to walk away like maybe this
is maybe i get in a new relationship
feel the same way about someone and then
in five years that love fades because
i've heard that i've heard i got scared
like people that have been in marriages
for a while were like yeah well love
fades like love fades and i was like
[ __ ]
did i just throw away the love of my
life because
it faded and i wasn't ready to settle
like i i just didn't think that you
should settle for something
we learned this lesson later yeah
exactly but you it's an unknown because
it's like maybe those older couples are
right you know stay with somebody that
knows you that loves you
um rather than like try to find this
fairy tale that's not possible
there's also sunk cost fallacy with
relationships where i'm like
i remember with an ex that i was with
i'm like i've been in this for so long
with this person
like four years of my life has been with
this person in my 20s
like i am going to make this [ __ ]
worse
when you're so young too it sounds like
such a big deal yeah and like i know
their family and like where we all get
on so well and like i can't imagine not
seeing them at christmas time all the
[ __ ] that you do to yourself
but then when you look at them every day
that isn't christmas day
you're like what am i doing here i don't
like this i'm not happy
yeah and that matters ultimately it felt
like i would rather be single and alone
forever and never find that guy and then
settle and be in a place where i don't
love the person i'm with
and but i just want to make them happy
you're in a rut your relationship is a
rut
yeah i think the feelings a lot of the
feelings that i have at the end of each
relationship
always reveal themselves to me in
hindsight where i'm like i thought i
would never get over that guy
or i thought i was never going to meet
anyone better than that and then the
next one was a little bit more
like suiting for me and then the next
one was like less of a liar you know so
it's like
yeah there's the others learning a lot
about yourself yeah relationship too
like so it's
and i think i'll never find someone as
cool as this or someone who understands
me as this and then like the next person
comes along they do understand me too so
it's just
it's just a natural reaction when you're
in the moment you're in your head you're
in this little kind of bubble of what's
going on but then when you step
out of it there's a lot more and choose
to see the opportunity here like
you have an opportunity now to work on
yourself yeah like you have a chance to
grow
on your own like these are not things
that everyone gets all the time
yeah so that was an interesting way to
start or should we break up with someone
who's already broken up but i guess it's
good to talk to like a firm
yeah like you will be happier ultimately
yeah by doing like following your
intuition and right
being like yeah it was it was an
expiration it
it was less of a breakup and more of
like oh our relationship expired
like yeah we're on to the next purpose
yeah your life
story so this one's a little longer okay
but this person has not broken up yet
um so we will determine their fate if
it's this long i'm like girl you took
your notepad out and you're writing a
you know paragraphs the answer is
probably yes but yeah clear you out
i haven't i haven't read it yet but just
by length alone i'm like first you know
the context of what he did
yeah yeah yeah that's true this is why
i'm gonna stay even though it sounds
like terrible but wait hear me
hear me out he's a good guy yeah yeah he
walked me across the street one time
and he walked on the side of the car
he's a good guy
okay my boyfriend and i are in a
long-distance relationship of three
years he lives in england and i live in
the usa because
yeah that's a long distance
ocean relationship isn't it in it and it
may
he constantly lied to me through our
relationship and cheated on me a few
times before
um i don't need to go any further
i don't know i want to hear a little bit
more about that
i chose to stay to work things out with
him he promises me
that he has is a changed man and of
course i give him the chance after
chance because i love him
and i want to make things work despite
me having broken trust broken heart and
insecurities developing from him lying
and cheating to me
he cheating on me fast forward two years
into our relationship i found on his
facebook that he may have used tinder
again
he claims that he didn't download tinder
again or use it i asked to see proof if
that
he wasn't cheating again and i asked to
see tinder data and facebook data for
proof
he feels that his privacy is like she
wants how do you get data to prove you
haven't used i don't know
i guess maybe browsing history history
but then it's like there's no history on
tinder
delete that but then she's but then
that's his private tinder like why is
she trying to look at his privately
that's super weird he feels that his
privacy is violated and won't show me
and of course me who has become the
crazy [ __ ] starts losing my
[ __ ] i start screaming and shouting at
him and arguing with him until we make a
compromise
because he's gaslighting i love it he's
good like you're crazy
stop violating my privacy even though i
cheated on you yeah because we're
in a long distance relationship he will
share his screen with me going through
the
data and he wants to control showing me
what's on the data
the thing is his data i don't know is
she like reading source code like
what's the data did he make you
shouldn't have to be a hacker to be in a
relationship
move let's move on good god the thing is
he won't choose a day to show me because
there's a lot of things going on in his
life right now
covet times are tough he can't his dad
is in the hospital because he's super
sick
and with his dad out of a job his family
won't be able to pay bills and put food
on the table
so his mom works his mom works as a lab
scientist at a school but is barely
getting paid due to covered reasons
and him and his sisters are going to uni
i don't have a job either to make it all
worse my boyfriend recently found out
that he has cancer
he doesn't jesus really he doesn't does
he really
i totally did i totally had the same
thing that's so wrong
for me to say that i don't want him to
have cancer and that's very sad if he
does
but for some reason because of all the
lying and like why is he in the worst
situation
possible why is she the only one who's
considerate though
she she's so considerate about
everything going on in his life yeah i
can name you all the things going on in
his life
but when it comes to her and needing one
thing he can't give her one thing wait
this will help soothe though okay is
there more he doesn't know what kind of
cancer he has yet because they won't do
further testing
that's ridiculous i got skin cancer
taken out in the middle of coding
to tell you where the cancer is
well where did you find it doctor oh
it's in your body
it's this in the general body we could
at least
or something i had to go get my cancer
test and i got a bad
i got an a plus on my cancer she's like
she's gonna ask for proof i gotta find
proof on the internet first like i need
to find a screenshot of cancer
and then i can pit tell her what kind of
cancer cancer makes it so i can't share
my screen with you yeah yeah
because the having the phone next to me
the radiation is bad yeah oh my god
yeah so i don't i hope he doesn't have
cancer but just
obviously it's very hard because i
wonder are there blood tests that can
show you like oh yeah you have cancer
somewhere but
we don't know where it's just in there
we don't know but
it sounds sus the whole thing sucks yeah
that's all okay
with all that going on in his life he
tells me to wait and he'll show me in
two months pass and i'm getting super
impatient
he's busy for two months what do you
think he promises me he will prove to me
he wasn't cheating it's been three or
four times now that we pick a date to
have him prove to me he isn't cheating
oh god this is
about showing me and he doesn't show me
proof it sucks and at this point it's
been almost three months of me waiting
is it right of me to get upset at him
with what he's going through now or is
he being a dick and he's avoiding and
hiding stuff from me again and i should
end the relationship
she's being worked my heart hurts so bad
yeah he
he's like she's like i honestly don't
even know if it's true that my
boyfriend's got cancer and his dad is
dying in the hospital
my boyfriend's lied to me so much in our
relationship that i honestly don't know
what's the truth or a lie anymore it's
horrible of me
to not believe any hardship he's going
through i just feel like everything he
claims he's
he's going through is all an excuse to
not have to show me he isn't cheating
am i being self-centered or am i being
too much am i being a [ __ ]
um or am i wrong for thinking and
feeling the way i do
uh yeah and she oh she's i guess
submitted this before and around of
should we break up and so
this is her second time submitting she's
like this is my sec i mean i'm still in
the same situation
no way i would like to submit a second
round of [ __ ] is there a show out there
that you could submit this to and
they're like you're being a [ __ ]
[Music]
i can understand like because they make
you sometimes when you're in those
relationships they say
i was told i was crazy so much that i
just didn't even know if i could trust
my own judgment anymore this is like who
i was when i was like 21.
yeah like i would i would like stay just
get
gaslit to [ __ ] hell like i mean and
then i would find
[ __ ] and i'm like i'm not crazy i don't
i can't i'm trying to remember why i
couldn't
just leave that guy but i guess it
really is like the those chemicals
especially when you're young and you're
new to love like she sounds like she's
young maybe she's not she sounds
like when you get addicted to that like
like you think this is the only thing
like it's almost like an addiction like
you think this is the only thing that
can make you happy so i can't let him go
i can't let him go and i don't know i
don't know how to
i think i was to shake you out of that
because i'm like well i wouldn't treat
someone else like that like there's no
way i would ever do that and so if he's
saying he loves me
i'm comparing it to what i know is love
like the way i love him
so how could he possibly be lying about
that i would never lie about having
cancer or my dad being in the hospital
so
am i wrong to think he's lying is that
me being like
delusional like and you start to
question yourself because
you would never do those things that's
something that we all need to
to remember is that we our intuition is
so [ __ ]
on point like when is it ever wrong like
so if you're feeling
that you are onto something you clearly
are on to something
and i don't know like hearing this girl
make so many so many excuses for him too
it's like she doesn't want to take the
truth
because she wants she probably feels
that validation of like just having
someone even though he's
around like in a whole another country
across the ocean it's like well at least
someone is my person yeah and so she
doesn't want to be completely alone
so she feels that need to be like well
as long as he's still my person
there must be reasons why he's doing
this like i'm gonna wait for him to
prove himself that yeah he's telling the
truth because he's my person
like i don't know it just sounds really
sad it kind of reminds me like a 90 day
fiance situation
like don't even live in the same country
and he's like i don't know she seems
like she might be flirting with other
dudes but i don't know oh yeah
anyway um just because it's obvious to
us it's obviously not obvious to her but
yeah
um you should break up
well she's already in the streets in the
u.s because she's not really she doesn't
really have anyone
yeah here and it's not gonna be that
different you'll just be
you won't be texting him what did you
pack up probably some new clothes
yeah get yourself a new wardrobe a new
life and uh
at an affordable cost so curtsy is one
of our sponsors
and i freaking love this app yes we have
a new sponsor this week
and curtsy they actually um gave us a
little bit of money to play with
yeah so we got to test this out oh you
got those
answers yeah they're from anthropology
originally so it's a thrifting app and
yeah i got like second hand a lot of
secondhand stores that i would
never spend full price at yeah you get
them for like a fraction of the cost and
they're brand new with tags
i personally because they gave us a
little bit of money to play with to
check out the app or whatever i was like
dope i'm gonna go buy some [ __ ]
designer label [ __ ] so that's what i did
because i actually
i what i'm doing is i'm like trying to
build up like a work wardrobe for when i
go back to work as an accountant so i'm
buying like very basic corporate
kind of designer type of stuff like from
the shoes to bags and like
clothes that are kind of like
appropriate for that type of job
so i went and i bought some coach stuff
um and it was actually new with tags so
it is a thrifting app but they do have
stuff that's new with tags and then the
stuff that i got well
there was a bag that was over 250 that
they actually even though it's um
like a person-to-person type of app like
they send it to the warehouse it got
checked
for authenticity authenticity and then
they mailed it to me so
it's pretty cool app i enjoy it and i
still look around from time to time i'm
like what's new
here like you know what are people
selling and there's there's so much
stuff and
i like how you can filter it too yeah
they have a lot of a lot of really cool
filters that you can use
oh and if you want to sell stuff on it
sorry i'm like obsessed yeah but
if you want to sell stuff on it they
have like you can order their shipping
kit for free so they'll send you the
packaging materials oh cool so you don't
have to pay for any of that
yeah that's really cute um yeah so they
have a ton of like
brands that everyone's heard of nike
urban outfitters champion like all kinds
of stuff
um selling clothes usually is kind of a
pain in the ass so like i usually just
dump it
like even expensive stuff i'll dump it
at like a a charity or whatever but i
think i'm gonna actually try to
um out get rid of some of my winter
stuff like through this app
so i think that'll be fun because i've
already bought stuff yeah now i want to
see what the selling experience is like
um if you have a if you want a
sustainable way to get
urban champion and lulu's delivered
directly to your door download curtsy
today
enter promo code mood for 15 off your
first order
to search for curtsy in the app store
it's c-u-r-t-s-y
curtsy enter promo code mood
for 15 off your first order uh don't
forget go to the curtsy
app and enter promo code mood and you
get 15 off
yeah and also another one of our
sponsors that i'm obsessed with i'm
obsessed with all of our sponsors
yeah like almost all of them i'm like
i've already been using it for years
so this one ritual vitamins um
i love them i've taken that since like
2017 yeah
since like my wedding for sure yeah it
makes it easy because
you always need vitamins like a
multivitamin especially for women
um and fish oil and this has everything
in one
and also it's a subscription service and
it's pretty affordable so it's a high
quality vitamin that gets delivered to
your door
every month and um it tells you all of
the
essentials specifically designed for
women right but they do have
uh multivitamins that are for men and um
children too they actually just came out
with a gummy version
for kids uh but i liked it because it
had like the essentials for women and
i'm actually now i've switched over to
their prenatal vitamins so i've been
taking those for a year that's what the
baby wants
the baby it's what the baby wants which
really is like it adds folic acid to it
but and i think people that even if
you're not trying for a baby if you're a
woman like you you kind of
do need that as you get older um so
uh ritual is a multivitamin reimagined a
multivitamin should
contain key nutrients and formed in the
forms that your body can actually use to
help fill the gaps in the diet
so no shady extras rituals delayed
release capsule designs um
high quality nutrients including vitamin
d3
and just two daily pills and it's
designed with your life stage in mind so
it's like i said available for women men
and teens and kids and they're
scientifically developed to help support
different life stages and it makes your
healthy habits easy that's what i liked
about it is i don't have to remember to
refill my vitamins like it just it comes
and if you need to skip a month they
have that option too because sometimes i
forget to take them
and then i'm like oh [ __ ] i have like
way too many
um so i just skip a month and then
they'll resume
i like these because they look cool too
they do it's like a liquid vitamin and
there's like a mint aftertaste
yeah yeah they have like little beads
and stuff
it looks very cool you feel cool when
you're doing you're like i'm the future
get key nutrients without the bs ritual
is offering
our listeners 10 off during your first
three months
visit ritual.com big mood to start your
ritual today that's ritual dot com slash
big mood 10 off yes yes
so where are we with this girl oh yeah
we told her that she should break out
yeah for sure
first of all it's not even like that
great he's he's a liar he drives on the
wrong side of the road
yeah they eat beans for breakfast over
there
yeah that's weird beans and toast no
thanks
no shame i don't like the food i really
don't i never did
those are my people but sorry
okay are you ready for our next one yep
okay we are going to determine a new
person's fate
my girlfriend and i same-sex
relationship so lesbian relationship
we're together for
eight years we recently were engaged in
november she had cheated previously like
four years into our relationship
but we worked through it so that was
like a half a relationship ago she
cheated but they worked
through it and by the way just as a
sidebar
like if you're gonna forgive your
partner for cheating like if you're
gonna work through it you cannot bring
that up ever again
but that's my whole philosophy unless it
happens again then it's like well you've
done this twice yeah
but you're gonna pretend like it was
only once now and then you should just
definitely break up yeah
but um but yeah i personally could never
handle cheating not even one time um but
if you are going to forgive it you have
to really clean slate it because that
shit's
difficult most people can't do that
which is why it's very hard don't get
[ __ ] married after then be like
well remember when you cheated on me
it's like what the [ __ ] are you doing
you just married this person
yeah you can't bring it up and hold it
over their head if you're gonna actually
forget them
not saying that this person did that but
so let's move on recently
we started having sex with some guy off
tinder then she would start seeing him
while i was at work because they were
both unemployed she's swinging the other
way so she's bisexual
okay she said we both were yeah sex with
us we're both bisexual
yeah okay yeah exactly um
you see you bring a man into the
relationship
and then she would start this guy's on
tinder and he's like these two chicks
weren't [ __ ] right now
crazy he's like jackpot yeah yeah um
she would start seeing him while i was
at work because they were both
unemployed
he told her that he had feelings for her
and then we went on a break
during our break we agreed to not sleep
with anyone however i found out she did
end up sleeping with him on the break
anyways which happened to be over
valentine's day weekend
i'm so confused because i still love her
and we have eight years together
we have two dogs we were engaged we were
engaged and about to buy a house
together
she is sorry now but i'm not sure if
she's just staying with me because it's
comfortable
it sounds like she is yeah she wanted to
go out and experience
a straight relationship she [ __ ]
left you over valentine's day like
that's that's kind of big
and that's a cheat like she cheated
again yeah because there was an
agreement
exactly oh my god this part pisses me
off so much because this happened to me
where
we were broken up yes but we both agreed
we weren't going to
have sex with anybody and then he broke
it so in my mind that's still cheating
because it's an agreement that we had
and then you broke it so even if we're
not in a relationship anymore
the trust is [ __ ] yeah it's still
[ __ ] like you still cheated to me
that's a betrayal
and i don't think that you should take
someone back after
that happened twice right follow me once
shame on
you follow me shame on me yeah
yeah don't fool me yeah yeah pack it up
that's
fine i'm speechless i'm speechless here
this one
come on man yeah this one's done it's
done
yeah but it's like you still love i get
where she's coming from
people want to justify i mean but people
want to justify like oh i mean they
don't have kids or anything
exactly put dolls dogs are they're furry
babies oh who cares better to get out of
the dogs
but that's what i mean they see the sun
cost fallacy i've been in this for so
long we're engaged
with all these life moments together
that's all wiped out we have to do
shared custody of the dog but wouldn't
it be great to have a partner you could
trust
like yeah i think that's way better yeah
what's the what's the next eight years
of like
wondering like never i mean they've
already pulled the rug out from
underneath you there is no stability
there like she could just leave
yeah for even for a man at any point it
sounds like wait
you dodged a bullet like you didn't buy
the house yet exactly you didn't
get married i like that she's sorry now
it's like
hey after i am very considerate yeah but
before i do whatever i want
but and then afterward i'll be very
considerate to you yeah i ate all the
cookies but
now i'm i would yeah i wish i didn't do
that but i did it
yeah that's nice it's just like
prolonging the inevitable i mean i feel
like at some point
it's going to fall apart so do you want
it to happen now
or to happen when you're like older and
it's harder
if you don't have trust you have nothing
you have literally nothing
your relationship is an empty vessel
we say pack it up we say oh i was gonna
say stay together
oh yeah holy [ __ ] wow how did we get
there that was a mismatch
okay how about this one guys should i
tell my friend
booty call fiance that he's cheating on
his face excuse me friend
friend booty call fiancee what my friend
fiance wait it's a
friend booty call
dash fiance what wait how could they be
fiance and friends
okay this is confusing as [ __ ] okay okay
you you let me try to cypher
yeah let's see where this goes my friend
and i have
been friends for 10 years we both went
through a whole phase
she has been having sex with a guy for
these 10 years on and off
only a booty call never a relationship
so she's friend with a hoe
she went through her whole face her
friend's still doing the whole [ __ ]
right that's what it sounds like yeah
okay
and ho not in a derogatory term like
it's just like we all have a hope
yeah we love o's we are hosting this
period in our lives where our body count
went up yeah that's all
means nothing to me uh three years ago
my friend found out he is engaged
with another woman and my ho friend has
no idea so i think there's three things
oh
tell her friend that the booty call
she's seeing i think she's a friend with
two of
eating on his fiance yeah but the way
she ordered it she's like he just found
out he's engaged
you're still gonna have to explain it to
me i'm confused okay so my friend and i
have been friends for 10 years we both
went through a whole
phase she has been having sex with a guy
for these 10 years on and off
only a booty call never a relationship
three years ago my friend found out he's
engaged with another woman
and she my friend had no idea so the
three years that
she was seeing this guy this guy was
engaged the whole time she had no idea
um she was upset but she continued to
have sex with him
now she knows the information is it's a
booty call yeah
but also maybe
no but like if i was a booty call and it
was like a
a good agreement that we were both booty
calls i
if i found out he was engaged i would be
heartbroken
contributed to like a home wrecking
situation like instead of just being
like a hook up but then we're still
sleeping with him afterwards
then that's the part that's the part i
don't agree with
um she was upset with them but she
continued to have sex with him he has
cheated on his fiance for so long
i stalk his fiancee on insta and she
seems so happy and her wedding day was
in december
due to covet she has postponed her
wedding day to may
oh girl my friend does not care if he
gets exposed and i'm wanting to expose
him
only because my friend doesn't care and
i feel very bad to the new girl that has
no clue
i know it's gonna it's going against
girl code but what about doing the right
thing excuse me what's going against her
what is
yeah girl code is telling i guess
ruining her friend's booty call
but then her friend said she doesn't
care yeah
so she goes i was a side chick with a
guy for many years and it's something i
um i regret and feel horrible about and
maybe that's why i want to help expose a
cheating guy
right well those are proper feelings
yeah i feel like you could save this new
girl from
getting married i want her to marry this
cheater no that's against girl
code i feel like the universe postponed
her wedding for a reason exactly
for you to step in step back sometimes
though i gotta say because i was
around a cheating situation yeah and and
i was friends with both
you were friends and so i didn't want to
jump in the middle of their marriage and
be like yo this is going on because i
didn't even [ __ ] know what was going
on until i saw it going on
because it was literally happening in
the room next to me and i was like holy
[ __ ] you're actually doing this you're
cheating
at that point what did you decide now
that you have the actual proof but but
this would be more like if you were
friends with
the guy the girl she was he was sleeping
with right like you were friends with
the person in the marriage that's a lot
better
it's harder both of them right exactly
so i was just like this is an impossible
situation i'm just gonna
like distance myself from them really
this girl's friend was the side chick
so the side chick doesn't care right so
it's like i get that
yeah no i think that that's good yeah
it's just i've been in a situation like
this where i'm like i'm not gonna
if i was to step in the middle of
marriage like that i know that they both
would have just [ __ ] hated me
yeah i know that i would have like
released some truth or whatever
but i think they would have found a way
to stay together no matter what same i
was friends with a couple
where but then do you want to be with
friends with people who are going to ice
you out when you try to help them no i
stopped being so
i'm like right so you stopped being
friends with him anyway so then why not
just be like hey guess what
this is happening because then you're
like stepping into someone else's
marriage yeah so it's like
it's like you're friends with both of
both of them and
who knows if they're even going to
believe you and then you're just known
as this person that
ruins a marriage or tried to ruin a
marriage one of them asked me to lie
for them and then i would not do that
so you just had to stop being friends
exactly i was like this is not a
situation i'm not gonna like
throw a grenade in and be like peace out
like like [ __ ] you guys i don't know i
think for
from a woman's perspective if i know
that her man's cheating on her and she's
act she's like she seems all happy and
like everything's all great i'm gonna
have to be like
look he's cheating on you if i was
friends with the side chick
totally fine i would tell the the girl
that's in the relationship no i would
tell the girl that's in the relationship
for sure i don't know it's easier said
than done because like i definitely was
friends with a different couple
that where it's like i love both of them
but yeah like it and it sucks like and
they seem happy in their marriage
so like i don't think it's my place
i would so i had these friends that like
there was something going on and and
they i the friend purposely didn't tell
me what was happening because
they knew that i would have said
something to their to the person
that they're with that they're cheating
on so i know that like i obviously have
never actually been in that situation
which i'm kind of glad that they kept me
out of it but
you know being the friend and then
knowing that my friend is doing
something wrong
and then betraying their
their partner partner who i'm also
friends with like i can't be in the
middle of that and be like
okay like no way dude i have to step in
whether that's gonna cost me the
friendship or not
listen i know i know some [ __ ] that
needs to be said i'm gonna [ __ ] say
it
yeah i'm not going to keep my mouth shut
for me it depends on how close we are
because like if i found out that
either one of you are cheating i'm
telling the other person yeah no that's
interesting
same with tiff in case if i found out
level of whatever
i would expect if it's like two or three
degrees away from me i'm like i'm not
your friend
anyway so it's not my best for me it was
a situational thing because the wife
had seen evidence before and refused to
believe it
and so i knew she felt like she was just
gonna hide it yes
and i would just like literally light
myself on fire and walk through the
living room
that makes sense if you know that she's
like kind of being like putting her head
on the scene
yeah yeah because she because like again
i was asked to lie for this person she
doesn't want to believe it
i was told to tell something to this
person that wasn't true
because she was asking questions about
something so then then
that's why i'm like wait she's not
putting this together herself
uh even though it's pretty obvious with
the evidence that she has
me doing this was not gonna help
anything yeah i just there's something
weird to me about being in a community
of friends and like
everyone knows something and you don't
so yeah if she's kind of like if you
know she's kind of like
ignoring [ __ ] then it's like all right
well that seems to be your [ __ ]
choice to just
you know ignore the truth based on the
evidence that she was given yes if you
guys all knew that my partner was
cheated on me and didn't [ __ ] tell me
like yeah
i would i would literally hate you
that's true i mean
yeah but it's also yeah yeah it's the
level closest i think
i don't think yeah i wasn't as close to
them as i am with you guys yeah so this
trick definitely needs to go
out and tell i mean even they're not
even yeah not even in the circle yeah
yeah exactly but that's what like if
there's a and
the side chick doesn't give a [ __ ] then
i'm definitely telling that girl
and saving her from marrying something i
i guess some people might see it as like
oh you guys just want to take down a
happy couple or
no or find it to be like oh y'all are
just a side chick haters or something
like i can see women trying to be like
why do you have to like tell them or try
to bring them down but i'm like that's
whatever their justification is like
maybe they think it's funny like some
girls are probably [ __ ] they're like
oh i'm the side chick like he actually
is with me
you know like yeah there's some
attitudes like that yeah so but
ultimately like her not marrying this
cheater
yeah like so regardless of what they're
or at least having the
motivation yeah she needs to know like
regardless if they're [ __ ] little
[ __ ] and like they're being [ __ ]
about it and like how your man's
cheating you know like
i could see girls being like just stay
out of it but also it's better
regardless of the motivation if she
knows he's a cheater i'm trying to think
about it like if i was the girl
that's finding this out i think i would
be thankful
i'd like even if they were very [ __ ]
about it even if they were like
yo man's feeding them yeah i'd still be
like is he
is that true benefit from this one oh
yeah well i i
felt like he was that's true i did my ex
i felt he was cheating and then
i asked the girl but i asked her right
and she wasn't
i don't think she thought she was a side
chick he was pursuing her
for a relationship it was overlapping
our relationship
and i asked her and he had lied to her
and said we were
completely broken up and all this stuff
and she had just been cheated on by
her boyfriend and so she felt for me and
she
made him confess to me she like made him
call me and
and tell me the truth because he had
been lying i had called him out on a
[ __ ] i was like i think
something's happening with this girl and
he swore up and down like he would never
and then she was like you need to call
her and tell her the truth and so she
was there when he called me
wow i'm trying to think if if there's
any circumstance where a cheater
shouldn't be exposed
i think it's more about like
i think shooters should always be
exposed but even if you don't do it
personally you could probably [ __ ]
find a way to like
hey hey yeah
it's tough it's tough because that one
situation i was in i was just like and i
was also in my early 20s i was just like
i don't
know if i wanna yeah like if it's like
say the fiance
in this story like if they had kids
together would you
tell like do you think that just let her
be
um ambivalent and not know and they have
kids like maybe the household would be
stable i know a reason
if i was if that guy was violent like
what if the fiance tries to get
revenge because he's pissed you ruined
his marriage or whatever
that's probably a reason i'd be scared
of i did have a friend
one time who she was the side chick and
i didn't know
the couple at all like who she was
sleeping with i knew the guy was
and i knew she had been sleeping with
him for a while and i knew they
the guy had just like got a house with
the girl
uh his like girlfriend i don't know if
she was a fiance or a girlfriend i can't
remember
but i remember going to that girl's
instagram and feeling so bad for her
because she did
she just like doted on him and she was
talking about how happy she was and like
they just moved in and she was like kind
of showing their life together and i
felt
so bad that she didn't have a clue and
then she even found
evidence and he somehow talked his way
out of it
yeah she let him talk his way out of it
as well yeah and i remember wanting to
step in and like let her know because i
felt like that was just
so awful but my friend at the time who
was the side chick
was like really wanted that to be her
man and so
she's like don't [ __ ] with this at all i
was like damn
i really want to save that girl oh man
that sucks
yeah staying loyal yeah
yeah it's a hard situation man but
ultimately if your friend doesn't care
the side chick friend yeah and you don't
have any skin in the game that's easy
yeah yeah i had a friend text me
recently she was like so-and-so told me
that our mutual friend so-and-so is
cheating blah blah blah should i and
then but she was so upset
that she found out because then now
she's put in a position where she like
you said yeah
and i'm like i get that but i still kept
telling her i was like i still feel like
you have to
say something you know but i mean i i
guess i could see why some people just
aren't
they they really don't want to meddle
yeah
but for me i'm just like dang like just
think about if that was you though like
if
if we all knew that he was cheating and
all of us were like oh i don't want to
meddle
you know and then you look around at
your friends and you're like really you
guys have known this for [ __ ] two
years and you didn't say anything
like how it's it's hard to not want to
it's so hard to get involved in other
people's business but then think about
what's the repercussion of not getting
involved too yeah exactly
and then you can weigh that option so
like for me if it's a if it's like a
friend of a friend of a friend and i
know they're cheating like there's no
repercussion for me yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] if they're mad at me
like they don't know me really we're not
friends so it's not my responsibility
but
yeah i think maybe i would have done it
differently now i'm way more mature now
but back then i was just so like oh my
god this is crazy because they had like
a long
marriage and yeah you saw you like
stopped being friends with them and then
you
just that was i just like you just
distance myself
and then i'm sure they don't even know
why we're not friends frankly
are they still married just out of
curiosity i think so yeah she's probably
just keeping her head in the sand and is
okay some people are
some people are just so desperate to
stay in a relationship that even if
they're getting cheated on they're like
it's okay yeah and like i said the
evidence was pretty glaring
so the the fact that he needed me to lie
about the evidence like come on bro
yeah she obviously was putting head in
the sand a little bit yeah
that situation though like it was so
outrageous that i don't know
if i was her i might not have believed
it either because it was like
just so hard to believe that that your
dude would actually do that
yeah exactly well anyway
thank you so much for submitting all of
your situations that last one i guess
wasn't a make
a breakup or not breakup but yeah it was
like a break them
up or not yeah yeah yes break them up
yeah
let her go back to the street yeah
help her pack her bags um if you want to
submit your
questions we we do ask for these like
once a month so
go follow us on instagram at big mood
girls and also go follow steve
where can they find you steve from me
[ __ ] they don't tell you podcast
yeah wherever you get your podcast we do
we do a lot of stuff like this quite
often so
yeah we do we have a breakup button on
ours we smash the breakup button quite a
bit
and smash that breakup button and check
out our sponsors i freaking love them
yes try the curtsy app that's pretty
cool i like it we'll see you next time
bye